The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DUANE BONING: So I want
to welcome everybody here
in Singapore-- or
there in Singapore,
and here in Cambridge.
My name is Duane Boning.
I'll be one of the two
lecturers for our class.
We'll get into some
of those logistics
and details in a
minute, but we've
got some preliminary things.
Since we've started
videotaping you already,
one thing you need to know
is there is a video recording
policy.
Pretty much everybody
here will be videotaped.
If you don't want
to be videotaped,
there are a couple of
seats here on the right.
If you do want to
be videotaped, you
can come and be
accessible and viewable.
Right at the front, you can see
there's these little red tabs
on the desk.
That's in the blind
spot of the video.
I think some of these
were being handed out
as you were coming in, but
if you didn't get them,
here's another copy of
that videotaping policy.
So what we do is most of these
lectures are, of course, live,
video linked with Singapore.
There are occasions
in the calendar
where it's a holiday in
one place or the other.
When it's a holiday
here, we don't meet.
When it's a whole holiday in
Singapore, but not a holiday
here, we will still
meet here in Cambridge,
but the video version
of the local lecture
will be available on the website
so that folks in Singapore
can catch up on that.
And in fact, we understand
the first one of those
is this coming Thursday.
Is everybody ready
for your holiday?
It's been a long, hard
term already, right?
Is that right, Singapore?
OK.
Yeah, that's the
Chinese New Year,
so there will be no class
meeting in Singapore
on Thursday evening.
Let's see.
OK.
Has everybody found their way
to the Stellar website already?
Anybody who has not seen the
Stellar website for this class?
I'm asking in part because,
if you are not actually
registered-- let me go to
the Stellar site here--
oh, this may not be
viewable in Singapore.
This is accessible only to
those registered in the class,
I believe.
So if you're having trouble
getting to the website,
please email me right away, and
we will add you to the roster,
even before you get registered.
It will be important,
because all
of the materials
for the class are
deployed through the website.
In fact, it'll be very rare when
we have any kind of handouts
to give in class.
Lecture notes, reading material,
reading back-up, assignments,
weekly problem sets--
all of that material
is through the website.
Now, what I will typically do--
let me see if I
can get back here--
usually I will try to have
the PowerPoint slides loaded
a day before the lecture.
One thing that I noticed in
a few past years is sometimes
little groups of students
would work together
and delegate somebody to
print out the lecture slides
and bring a set of copies
for their little group.
So for example, the LFM
students would often
have one person printing out
that morning or the night
before, if they were available.
So you guys can self-organize.
If you actually like having
any kind of print-out
to take notes on a copy
of the PowerPoint slides,
feel free to print those
out or self-organize
to share that duty.
Again, we're not going to
be making copies available
directly in the class.
So what I want to do, first
off, is talk a little bit
about the class and the assumed
prerequisites for the class,
and then we'll come
back and I want
to get us to know each other.
I know many of you have
had some classes together.
Others of you are perhaps
new to each other,
so want to share a
little bit of experiences
so we know what the
basin of experience is--
because this class is meant
to be fairly interactive.
It is a manufacturing
process control class,
and one of the best things
about it is many of the students
in the class have an
awful lot of experience.
For example, the
students and the leaders
for manufacturing program,
LFM, are typically
coming from several years
of industrial experience.
Similarly, students
have had a lot
of experience, whether it
be doing experimental work
with processes in--
as part of their program,
or what have you.
So it is meant to
be interactive.
We depend on you sharing
your experiences,
your insights, your doubts.
In many cases, those can be
often the most interesting part
of the subject--
say, I tried that-- didn't work.
Here's why-- because a lot
of the classes about tools
and experiences for dealing
with manufacturing processes.
And then we'll get into a
little bit more of the details,
some of the course schedule,
and some of the other logistics.
Jumping ahead a little
bit here, there's
kind of a long chain listed
formally on the course
catalog for prerequisites--
says things like 2.008,
or 2.810, or 6152J,
and then also a couple of other
subjects like 6041 or 15064J.
What we intend to convey with
these prerequisites is, number
one, they're not specific
hard prerequisites
for those subjects.
What we mean to convey is
you should have hopefully
some substantial experience
with some manufacturing process.
So that's things
like 2810, 6152J.
So 2810 is essentially the
manufacturing physics subject--
manufacturing processes
subject in course two.
I recognize some
of you for that.
I think I gave a guest
lecturer in that subject
on semiconductor manufacturing.
So that would be one example.
6152J is a course six,
electrical engineering computer
science subject on
microfabrication--
not only semiconductor, but
also MEMS microfabrication.
And so that would be another
example through coursework,
where you might have gotten
that kind of experience.
And then similarly, you
might have actual true
industrial experience.
So the goal here is actually
to just go deep enough
or build on a deep enough
knowledge of some process
technology.
This semester of the
subject, I will actually
be using semiconductor process
technology a little bit
more than we have some
semesters in the past
to illustrate, and
demonstrate, and to get
some practice with
some of the concepts
that we're dealing with here.
But many of the
problems will also
deal with macroscopic
processes, from metal
bending to forming and
other sorts of processes.
A little later, we expect Dave
Hardt, who is the collector.
He'll be here.
And his background
especially emphasizes
the panoply of mechanical
and broad based process
technologies, whereas my
experience is a little bit more
solidly in microfabrication--
both in semiconductor,
and more recently,
in micro-electromechanical
systems, or MEMS fabrication.
So that's one of
the prerequisites.
Now, the other prerequisite
that we kind of assume--
and if you don't have, you
might be doing a little bit
of quick background reading--
is indicated by things
like 6041 or 15064,
and that is some basic
probability and statistics.
We'll actually be developing
quite a bit of the statistical
machinery, so if you don't--
haven't had a full subject
in that, not to worry--
I recognize many
of you also from--
is it 2.853, 2.854?
Get that subject right--
that's Stan Gershwin's
manufacturing process?
What is it?
Manufacturing
systems-- manufacturing
systems, where we had a two
or three-lecture sequence
on basic statistics and
statistical modeling.
We'll actually
revisit some of that,
so you'll see some of
that again, but then
be applying that to
problems of manufacturing.
I'll go over this
detail, and then we'll
come back to get some
introductions from you guys.
This semester we actually
have two required textbooks.
The great thing is a
new book has come out.
It came out nominally 2006,
but it was only available
starting last year.
And that's a book by Gary
May and Costas Spanos.
Gary May is at Georgia Tech.
Costas Spanos at UC Berkeley,
and they had developed a course
on semiconductor
process control that
was very close to a subject
in the dim, dark past
that I used to teach dedicated
entirely to semiconductor
process control.
So finally, we have
a book for that.
It's a nice condensed book, and
you all should try to get that,
because we're going
to have readings
from this book starting
pretty quickly.
So you might have
to go to Amazon,
do two-day shipping or
something like that.
If somebody has
Amazon Prime, you
can use that and
get free shipping.
I don't know if
any of you do that.
The other book is Introduction
to Statistical Quality Control.
This is more broad based.
May and Spanos illustrate
everything the semiconductor
process technology.
Montgomery is basically a
statistical process control,
a little bit of
design of experiment.
It really emphasizes the
statistical machinery
that we're going to be using.
So you are expected
to either go and get
both of those--
both of these books
have been put on reserve
in the MIT library,
so if you don't want to spend
the money, you can, I guess,
do the painful thing of
trying to go to the library
and read there.
At least the Montgomery
book is a great book
to have on your
bookshelf long term.
It'll be a great reference
book throughout your career.
The semiconductor process
control-- certainly,
if you're going in the
semiconductor area, that's
also very useful.
OK, so the grading
in the class--
the way this works
is we will have--
I think it's something like
eight weekly problem sets,
primarily in the first
2/3 of the class.
And then, in the last
third of the class,
we stop the problem sets and
you'll go into a team project.
The problem sets will
comprise about 40%
of the grade in the class.
We'll have two quizzes--
one about a little bit more
than a third of the way through,
another one a little bit more
than 2/3 of the way through.
Those are about 40% of
the grade in the class.
The good thing about having
those quizzes during the term
is we do not have a final exam.
Anybody heartbroken about that?
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
However, the reason
we don't is that,
in that last third
quarter of the class,
we switched gears a
little bit and ask
you to start applying some of
the techniques and tools that
will have been talked
about through most
of the semester
in a team project.
I'll talk more
about what that team
project is a little bit later.
So that's meant to be a
fairly substantial effort.
The team project is going
to be a team project.
It's going to be typically
three-student teams.
And of course, that should be
very collaborative in nature.
In contrast to that,
the other assignments
are meant to be
individual efforts.
Now, working on
the problem set, I
think it's great to interact,
talk with each other
to understand the problems,
even to bounce off
possible lines of attack
or solution approaches,
but where we mean--
especially on the assignments--
the weekly assignments,
the problems sets--
is everybody should do
their own independent write-up.
I find that writing
and explaining not just
writing down the answer
number, by the way.
We will expect
actual articulation
of your thought process.
That should be an
individual effort.
Now, we'll come back to that
the assignments a little bit.
We'll try to emphasize this,
perhaps, as well a little bit
more on the
assignments themselves.
The perspective I'd
kind of like you
to take on these
weekly problem sets
is not that you're trying to
come up with the answer number
like you might on an exam
or something like that,
where you just needed
the number, but instead,
a little bit of what I think of
as a practicing manufacturing
perspective--
I couldn't call it an
industrial perspective
or an academic perspective,
but the key thing
that you have to
do, and will have
to do throughout your
career is convince.
So you have to convince
us that the answer
that you're putting down makes
sense, why it's reasonable.
So you need to articulate
the thought process,
not just come up with answers.
And that's part of the
reason why we really
want that to be an individual
effort, an individual write-up.
And of course,
everybody's already
gotten to the course URL.
So going backwards a step
here, let me introduce--
I hoped that Dave
would be here by now--
must be having a very
difficult decision point
and in the voting booth
there-- who to vote for.
Again, I'm Duane Boning.
I'm a professor of electrical
engineering and computer
science.
Dave Hardt.
Will be here a little bit later.
Let me introduce for you
the teaching assistant,
Hayden Taylor.
We do have microphones here.
Why don't you say
a couple of words?
HAYDEN TAYLOR: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yeah-- good.
There's the camera.
HAYDEN TAYLOR: Hello, Singapore.
I'm Hayden.
I'm in electrical engineering.
I work with Duane on
manufacturing approaches
for microfluidic devices.
We work a lot with polymers.
And I'm excited to work
with you all this time.
Feel free to email
me at any time.
I'll be organizing
office hours, and I'll
announce that on the website
when the time has come.
For those of you in
Singapore, I suppose
we'll have to have
virtual office hours.
I'm very happy to talk
over Skype or something
like that, if you want, so
feel free to drop me an email.
Thanks.
DUANE BONING: And
Hayden just got
back a little over a week ago--
is that right-- from Singapore.
HAYDEN TAYLOR: That's right.
DUANE BONING: [? We ?]
spent a couple of weeks
there for some of the
SMA program things.
The core secretary
will be my assistant
over near my office in EECS
headquarters in building 38.
And that's
[? Charlene Blake. ?] So if you
have some administrative
questions,
your best bet is probably
emailing Hayden and me
directly.
I'll be the lead
lecturer this term.
Normally, Dave Hardt
is the lead lecturer.
He's actually nominally on
sabbatical this term, but--
so I'll be taking care of more
of the administrative things,
and he'll get to
give fun lectures.
So if you have administrative
things, please--
probably best to contact
either me or Hayden directly.
If you have questions
or need to drop off,
for example, late
problem sets, that
can be done with [? Charlene. ?]
And we'll have to have to
let [? Charlene ?] know
that she really outdid
herself on the breakfast here.
So at any time, as soon
as you're done with one,
we have lots more
to eat, so feel
free to wander over and
grab a little bit more.
OK, we'll dive back
into a little bit more
about the course, but I thought
it would be a little bit
fun to just quickly go around
and hear a sentence or two
about--
and I'm particularly
interested in what kind
of process background, or
manufacturing background,
or technology
background you have--
or if you don't have much
background, what kind of areas
you're especially interested in,
or potentially interested in.
So we'll do that quickly here
on the Cambridge end first.
I know many of you, again, have
been taking classes together,
so you know each other
better than I you.
I recognize some faces
here a little bit.
But this is part of my way to
get to you as well as for you
guys to get to know each other.
OK, let me go through a
few of the other logistics,
and then we'll start
getting into a little bit
of introductory material.
I think we've already
done some of that.
Let me come back to
the team projects,
because I think
it'll be important
for you folks to be
starting to think very
early about possible projects
and possible team formation,
because that will help--
as you're learning some
of the tools and techniques
in these different kinds
of topical areas, you
can pay more attention,
because you'll
know, OK, I really
want to think about
process diagnosis
for this particular
project, or what have you.
So the typical kinds of topics--
generically, the topics
in these team projects
involve things like
process diagnosis;
process improvement,
often with a little bit
of statistical process
control, detection,
and debug kinds of things;
process optimization
and robustness--
things like use of
design of experiments
to characterize the
process, and then
seek to optimize some
outputs, as well as minimize
some variations and get
to a robust process;
and then a number of more
advanced applications,
perhaps dealing with things
like yield modeling or defect
modeling--
these sorts of projects.
And the basic expectation
in these team projects
is you'll need to
learn a little bit
more background on
the basic process
and what the problem is.
A really interesting aspect of
these projects is it's best--
it really works
nicely if we can tap
into a nice rich set
of existing data,
or in some cases, even
generation of new data
arising out of either
your past experience
or your current research.
So for example, one of the,
say, typical three-team members
might have access to--
hopefully only public,
shareable-- nothing secret--
public data from
their work experience.
Some of you may have
generated a big set of data
for your master's
thesis, or this or that,
and we're only able to look
at this aspect of the problem,
because that was
the key question,
but it was sort
of nagging at you.
There's all this other
rich data that you
would have thought it
interesting to look
at from other perspectives--
things like building very simple
response surface models for.
But you didn't really have the
chance to go down that path.
So keep your mind open,
thinking ahead to the project
as we go out-- go
throughout the term,
and say, oh, that's
an interesting topic.
That's an interesting technique.
That reminds me of a
very interesting data
set that I came across back
a year ago or whatever--
because that might form
the basis for a very
interesting team project.
The output of this
are two parts.
There will be a
world presentation.
So the team will present--
in fact, the last
two class periods,
the very last week of
class, will be dedicated
to these team presentations.
And then there will also
be a project report.
Unlike the problem
sets, where everybody
writes their own
separate problem set,
the team writes
the project report.
So that's one document that
comes together from the team.
Good-- so let me pop back.
We're not going to ask
you who you voted for,
but we figured it was a
tough decision, because it
was taking a little while.
We've already done
all the introductions,
so now you, fortunately,
know most everybody.
DAVID HARDT: I hope
everybody knows that I
got dressed for the occasion.
What am I [INAUDIBLE]?
DUANE BONING: You have to
wear a tie to vote in the US.
You may not know that.
DAVID HARDT: For those of you
who don't already know me,
I'm David Hardt.
And I'm actually on sabbatical
this semester, which
means I don't teach
any classes and I
don't sit on any committees.
DUANE BONING: Why do you wear
a tie if you're on sabbatical?
DAVID HARDT: So I'm here
today to sit on a committee
and do some teaching.
Yeah.
But I welcome you all
to probably the best
class at MIT--
and hello to all of our students
there in Singapore as well.
I hope you're
enjoying the weather.
It's beautiful here.
And the only reason
I'm late is that I
had to drive the other way to
get to the polling station,
and I got trapped by
a huge traffic jam.
So I'm a dedicated voter.
DUANE BONING: Thank you, Dave.
OK, so let's get a
little bit into the--
an overview of what
we're going to be dealing
with throughout the
semester, and then dive
in a little bit on some
concepts and basic background
and terminology.
So some of the key ideas that
we're after in this subject
is really dealing with basically
the problems in manufacturing.
And the biggest problem
of all is really
dealing with quality and
manufacturing variation.
Other aspects of
manufacturing are often
very particular to the specific
process technology that's
arising, but there's a
lot of very generic issues
with variation, and the
control, and elimination,
and modeling of the
process, and the variation,
and ways to reduce it.
So in some sense,
dealing with variation
is one of the key
themes in the subject.
And what we're going to start
with in the first couple
of lectures is basically
dive in, get a little bit
of process physics background.
On Thursday, we'll dive
in a little bit more
on semiconductor fabrication,
and then, on Tuesday, we'll
see a variety--
Dave will talk about a variety
of forging and other process
examples that give a wider
perspective on manufacturing,
and the physics that
are at work, and where
variation naturally, inherently
arises in those processes.
Then, well, once we've got a
little bit of a feel for where
variation comes
from, we want to dive
into some of the techniques for
understanding that and dealing
with it.
And that really gets us
into statistical models.
And we'll talk in great
length about the contrast
between physical models
of the process based
on detailed understanding
of the specific mechanisms
at work versus empirical
modeling of the process based
on data--
data and observations.
The wonderful thing
about data is it's real
and it encompasses all of
both the ideal behavior
and the non-ideal behavior.
And a lot of what we've
dealing with, again,
is the problems, really
trying to understand
where variation is coming from,
what its characteristics are.
If we can start to get a model
for some of that variation,
now we've got a
handle that we can
use to try to eliminate it--
either eliminate it
up front or control it
and compensate for it.
Some of the techniques that
we deal with for dealing with,
again, that data is
building effects models,
designed experiments.
You may have run across
DOE, design of experiments.
It's a form of
statistical technique,
and we will be learning
the details of that
and applying some
of those approaches
with basic input-output
data sets and data models,
both in specifying the
right set of experiments
to perform to very
efficiently sample sample
our process, and then
the ways to model that.
And perhaps one of the
most important ways
of using those empirical models
that we get of the process
is to improve the process, do
process optimization, really
looking for improved operating
points that have reduced
sensitivity to variation, that
really improve the robustness,
as well as meet
multiple objectives.
So we'll do a little bit of
optimization-- multi-objective
optimization coverage as well.
So let's talk a little
bit about, what are the--
oops-- what are the goals of
manufacturing process control
and manufacturing processes?
What are some of the
key characteristics you
would have of a good process?
What are the things
you would like
to either minimize or optimize?
So I already gave you
an advanced look at one.
I'll throw out one.
Of course, we're
very often interested
in minimizing the
cost, and cost rises
in a lot of different ways.
What are some of the
ways that cost arise?
There's the inherent
materials coming in.
What are some of the other
costs associated with a process?
Anybody-- Singapore as well--
AUDIENCE: Labor.
DUANE BONING: Labor, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
overhead, support.
DUANE BONING: Overhead, support.
AUDIENCE: Time.
DUANE BONING: Time.
Yeah, in fact time process--
time is certainly
a characteristic
that we might want
to optimize for.
That would be a
typical characteristic.
Cost has many of these flavors.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Setup costs--
DUANE BONING: Setup costs--
so setup costs are
an interesting one.
In various times,
we'll touch on some
of these operational issues.
Many of you have had
[? 2853. ?] We said--
which was really about
manufacturing systems
and things like
scheduling, throughput--
those kinds of issues.
And so time is a little
bit of that as well--
not just the inherent
manufacturing,
physical action on
the product time,
but also transport time-- all
of these kinds of other issues.
This subject will not be
dealing so much with logistics.
It'll really be much
closer to the things
that impact directly
the product itself.
But certainly, setup time
can have an interaction--
processes setup in general
can have a strong impact
on processed quality.
Very often, for example, in
semiconductor processing--
maybe this will resonate
with your experiences
in other processes--
if we change substantially
the process setup
in a particular
piece of equipment,
the first few wafers will
behave very differently
before the equipment
gets to a stable state.
Sometimes we even
run dummy wafers
in order to
equilibrate that setup.
So setup is a good one.
Some more-- what
are other things?
I'm sorry--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: [INAUDIBLE].
Certainly.
AUDIENCE: Equipment.
DUANE BONING: Equipment, yep.
We want to use the equipment
as efficiently as possible,
and maintain it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] a good
machine or a bad machine--
DUANE BONING: Good machines
and bad machines-- absolutely.
And in fact, probably
the first third
of the class, the classic
statistical process control,
will be all about detecting
whether the equipment is
behaving as it should.
Is it in a good state
or in a bad state?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: So here
we had quality control--
AUDIENCE: And rework.
DUANE BONING:
--and rework, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Energy.
DUANE BONING: Energy, yeah.
Yes, that's a good point.
Actually, I think, dealing
with energy, as well
as the consumption of materials
and the output of materials,
is becoming a more
and more interesting
aspect of manufacturing
processes.
Let's see.
When was it?
Sunday night-- just to
share another anecdote--
I was serving on a panel at a
big semiconductor conference.
Actually, it's the
semiconductor--
biggest circuit
design conference
in the semiconductor industry.
And I was on a panel all
about environmental or green
manufacturing.
And so the reduction
of energy usage
is becoming a very big deal, as
well as the output of things--
in semiconductor side, output
of global warming gases and so
on-- the reduction of those.
So that's a good point.
By the way, I was on a panel
at 7:30 on Sunday evening.
People here-- what
happened on Sunday?
That was Super Bowl here.
I was not very happy to
have to attend the panelist
dinner the second half
of the Super Bowl,
but as it turned out, I'm
very glad I missed it.
OK, so we've hit some of
these other ideas here.
Here's one that
nobody mentioned.
Flexibility is also very key
in manufacturing processes
as well.
We're increasingly finding
that the same manufacturing
line needs to be
adaptable rapidly
to be able to deal with a bigger
product mix than ever before.
So some of the focus
in this subject,
again, is going to really be on
the processes, and variation,
and quality in the processes.
A little bit bigger emphasis is
going to be on unit processes.
The entire aggregation of the
overall sequence of product
to make the overall--
or sequence of processes,
aggregation of the unit
processes to make the entire
process line, and process flow,
and the final
product is important.
We'll touch on some of these
kinds of things of stack up
of quality across
multiple processes,
but we'll be-- end up
emphasizing developing
techniques like statistical
process control, design
of experiments and optimization,
with a little bit more
of an emphasis on
the unit operations.
Part of the reason is more and
more for really high-quality
manufacturing--
the recognition is
you can't simply
inspect or hope to control at
the end of the overall process.
You have to have every unit
process along the way running
as effectively and at the
highest quality possible.
So again, the
number one emphasis
here is going to be
dealing with maximizing
quality, conformance to
specifications, and so on.
And some of these other
things that we've already
talked about here--
things like improving
throughput, improving
flexibility, reducing cost--
those are going to be secondary.
There will be interactions
with some of these topics
that you have run
into or might run
into another in other subjects.
And actually, a very
interesting area of research--
in fact, an active area of
research of Stan Gershwin,
who some of you had in 2853--
is this interaction between
quality and quantity--
that is, typical
operations and how
you manage the sequencing
of parts through the line--
the interaction between
throughput and quality--
for example, dealing
with issues of setup,
dealing with issues of slight
degradations in quality
and how that might impact things
like scheduled maintenance
or unscheduled maintenance.
So it's a very
interesting topic.
We'll occasionally, again,
overlap slightly with that,
but our number one emphasis here
is dealing with the process,
understanding and
modeling the process,
and dealing with
quality and variation.
So here's a few typical
process control problems.
I'll share a couple of these.
And just to wake up
Dave, on the next slide,
we'll let him say a
few words about some
of the other examples.
So here's a typical example.
Probably, in fact, the
number one problem--
or number one challenge in
semiconductor manufacturing
is the minimum feature
size is very, very
small-- becoming smaller with
each technology generation.
The minimum feature
size is typically
the channel length of an
individual MOS transistor.
That's often the most critical
parameter, and it varies.
With current
technology, we're down
in heavy-duty manufacturing
at 90 nanometers.
Some of the leading
edge manufacturers
have gate or channel patterned
lengths of 65 nanometer.
Occasionally, you'll hear
those terms thrown out.
What that means is the minimum
feature size being patterned
is about 65 nanometers wide.
That's small.
That's tiny.
And as we continue to
scale, that variability
in the width of that is becoming
tougher and tougher to achieve.
So very often, there will be
challenges on the manufacturing
line to detect--
monitor, detect,
and then compensate
for those kinds of variability.
An emerging technology--
here's an interesting one
that connects up
with, for example,
some of the Singapore MIT
Alliance research efforts.
A DNA diagnostic chip might
have uneven flow channels.
So for example, here, these
are often microfluidic devices
manufactured through
embossing processes, where
one might be using
a polymer and trying
to create channels that
might be 10 microns wide, 10
microns deep--
and maybe, in some places,
very, very narrow, for example,
or very, very shallow--
maybe 20 to 40 nanometers deep.
I mention those because
those are actually
real numbers for some
of the researchships
that are being developed here at
MIT in electrical engineering,
mechanical engineering, and
elsewhere-- very interesting
properties, when one gets
down to that small dimension.
And some of those
properties depend
critically on those
dimensions, as you can imagine.
So in fact, the
manufacturing process problem
is, how do you
get processes that
work in a controllable fashion?
How do you inspect and
detect feature sizes,
geometric parameters,
roughness of the geometry,
as well as some other
material properties in order
to achieve the
optimal functionality
that one might need--
for example, controlling the
flow of individual DNA from one
place to another through these
incredibly tiny, tiny channels?
What's another example?
Somebody mentioned assembly.
Assembly is a
manufacturing process,
and the worst example of
this is that toys that come
disassembled-- they
never fit, at least when
I try to assemble them at home.
Geometric fit and how those
imperfections can build up,
even if--
an interesting aspect--
even if a few parts
are close to nominal when
you try to put them together,
sometimes the aggregate
doesn't work out so well.
And then there may
be other example--
for example, very high-density
electrical connectors.
And I think, Dave,
you had some example--
this comes out of
an LFM thesis, or?
DAVID HARDT: No,
this was actually
research we did [INAUDIBLE]
a number of years ago.
And it's actually just like--
it's actually a
trend with all these
that [INAUDIBLE] for years.
Of course, [INAUDIBLE].
DUANE BONING: Can you guys
in Singapore hear Dave?
No?
AUDIENCE: No, we cannot hear.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID HARDT: [INAUDIBLE]
mic's not working.
Just because this
is sort of a theme--
you can imagine electrical
connectors-- big heavy ones,
like used in cars or in old
electronics back in the tube
days, where you could grab hold
of some of these connectors
with your hand--
just the metal part itself.
Now, as electronics has
become more and more dense,
as things have become
smaller and smaller,
the requirement for higher and
higher density of connectors--
if not just to handle
these high-density chips,
but just look at the back of
your computer-- some of those
connectors there-- particularly
the interconnect type
of connectors.
Well, the industry
that made that
made it the same way for
years, and it worked fine.
And it's a great example of
how variability is actually
a relative term.
And so the variability
was relatively small.
It was small relative to
the characteristic dimension
that you needed.
But as that shrunk down,
these major manufacturers
found out that they
really couldn't
use their old
technology to meet this.
Of course, they went through
a lot of the procedures
we're going to go through
and they improved things,
but they couldn't
meet those dimensions,
and had to make a
technology change as well.
DUANE BONING: This
is my sneaky way
to get an extra [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID HARDT: Also, on this
minimum feature size--
and I'd ask Duane
to comment on this--
I was once with a
gentleman from IBM Research
who told me they were
just now-- this was maybe
five, six years ago--
just now getting
into some of the
advanced techniques
that we're going to talk about
near the end of the term here.
And I was a little
bit surprised,
but then he pointed out,
back when the feature
size on the chips was large--
I don't know what large
was-- micron scale or several
microns--
the inherent variability
of the processes was fine--
fine to manufacture
these things.
But when you get down
to the nanometer range,
all of a sudden, you have to
look at some other techniques.
So there are these
timeless things,
like toys that
don't fit together
and other things related
to larger dimensions,
but then this idea of the
ever-shrinking mechanical
dimensions of things leads to
an ever-increasing importance
of process control.
So our future is guaranteed.
DUANE BONING: I'll skip
ahead, because maybe [? not ?]
going through all of these, but
if there's another one or two
of these from your experience
that you wanted [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVID HARDT: Well, these are
three large-scale issues.
This is usually where
I ask if anybody here
works for Boeing or any
other airframe manufacturer.
DUANE BONING: We
have some automotive.
We have some [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID HARDT: Yeah.
The automotive actually
does a lot better
on variation control,
because they have--
as you'll see, it helps
to have some volume
and to be able to learn
and to get your processes
in steady state.
Things like airframes are
still sort of one-off.
And because of the
large dimension there,
it's really not an unpleasant--
it's not a pleasant thing
to watch two halves of an
airplane being put together--
although they've gotten a lot
better than they used to be.
What was it they used to say--
that the number of thousands
of pounds [INAUDIBLE]
flying in a 747?
[INAUDIBLE] we're also
going to talk later--
actually, I'm not sure
we will this term,
but there's an
interesting LFM thesis
done on these plastic throttle
bodies for fuel injection.
This is a little
bit different issue.
This was an entirely different
way of making a classical part.
It had been made for
years out of aluminum--
machined aluminum--
well-defined process,
well-understood process control.
Then, for good and
sufficient reasons--
mainly weight and
production economy--
they went to injection
molded parts,
and variation became
a big problem.
And how to get rid of
it was a-- was and still
is an interesting issue.
So a number of things come
up, often because of change--
not always just because
of things being in stasis.
DUANE BONING: Thank you.
So again, some of
these points that Dave
made about, for example, the
question or example you posed
on semiconductor manufacturing
we'll talk a little bit more
about on Thursday,
because it was
a very interesting
transformation
from defect-oriented problems
as the real yield and quality
limiter to dimensional control.
And essentially, parametric
variation is the killer now.
OK, so one of the things--
this connects up again also to
a point that Dave just made--
is that there is an evolution
of manufacturing process control
many industries
had gone through.
And you will often
see a trajectory
where an industry may actually
start with a process that
is not all that stable,
and they essentially
have to inspect every
single part that comes out--
100% inspection may have
relatively high scrap rates--
even a few percent,
for example--
with low throughput, and
correspondingly high cost.
So this might be thought
to be a characteristic
of immature processes,
but it's also
a characteristic of
incredibly complex processes.
So you would really
like to avoid that.
Quick question for-- well, some
of the guys from semiconductor
know this.
Do we have 100% inspection
of semiconductor chips today?
What do you think?
Do you think every
single chip that
comes off the line gets
inspected, measured,
verified that it produces?
Do we have high costs or--
somebody who knows the answer--
well, I think perhaps it
depends on what the chip is.
You think every
single microprocessor
chip gets inspected before it
gets packaged and put in a PC?
You bet.
On the other hand--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Oh, absolutely.
A microprocessor chip might sell
for a couple hundred dollars,
so it's worth it.
Now, if you're talking about
a semiconductor chip that
is a discrete diode
worth probably
a fraction of a penny in
terms of the manufacturing
cost, yeah, you--
it's a much more simple
and less complex thing,
and you probably don't
need 100% inspection there.
But most integrated circuits,
at the end of the day,
still need inspection
at the end.
Yeah, Hayden?
HAYDEN TAYLOR: I thought
it might be worth
remarking that I think--
DUANE BONING: Speak loudly.
AUDIENCE: Can everyone
hear me in Singapore?
No.
DUANE BONING: Just shout.
HAYDEN TAYLOR: OK.
I think Intel, when
they test their chips,
they determine what
the maximum operating
frequency of any given
chip is, and they sort them
so the chips that happen to
operate at the faster end
are put in more
expensive machines,
and those that are slower
go in the cheaper machines.
So they actually get
some extra benefit
from the testing process.
DUANE BONING: Right.
So based on the quality
or the performance,
they can bin the chips and
get differential pricing.
Of course, they would be most
beneficial if all of the chips
operated at the high end.
And so in some sense,
that's both a limitation
and an advantage.
You can get a premium for
the highest performing.
But it's a great example
of the range of variation
and the effective, ultimately,
on the end performance.
A next step typically
in some of the evolution
of these manufacturing
processes involve--
whoops-- involve rework,
both at the end of the line,
but more often pushing
down to unit processes--
where, if you could
do a inspection,
you still have limited
control perhaps
over the individual
unit process,
but you can inspect it,
determine something went wrong.
And if there is a possibility
of fixing it then and there,
now you've got a big advantage.
We already talked about also
high durability at changeover,
and that's an example
we already talked about,
about how cost rate and
flexibility are linked.
Of course, all of these--
if you can get quality up,
get to higher and higher yield--
that has a dramatic effect,
perhaps the strongest effect
on overall throughput
and the optimal output
from your manufacturing plant--
especially in those industries
where yields may not
be all that high.
For example, in many of the
semiconductor processes,
if you have 90% yield on a
very complex microprocessor,
you're doing pretty well.
That's not great, is it?
Can you imagine 90% output of--
90% functioning output
of syringe needles
that we saw, where 10% of them
were defective in some way?
That wouldn't be very
satisfying, I think.
OK, so one of the
things that we're
going to do a little bit in
the next couple of lectures--
and I'm going to talk about
a little bit generically
to set the stage for that last
10 minutes or so of class--
is characteristics of
manufacturing processes--
in fact, something of
a taxonomy that Dave
will cover on
Thursday based on some
of the inherent characteristics
of the physical action
of manufacturing processes.
And we've already
chatted a little bit,
and we'll see more as we
dive into those processes
about why they don't
always work correctly.
So here I'm going to try to get
a little bit of the terminology
out and give you a little bit
of a framework for thinking
about the processes,
and then some reflection
on the different
segments of the subject
that we mentioned are
coming up, and how
they relate to a very-high level
generic view of the process.
So the key idea in a
process, of course,
is that we have some part that
we want to produce at the end.
We do that by working
on a work piece.
There is some physical material
that we are transforming
in some important way.
We are changing the geometry.
We are changing the material
properties of that part.
How do we do that?
Well, we have to
subjected to some process,
and we do that through
equipment, and in some cases,
parts of the
equipment-- things like
tooling that come in
contact with the part.
So some examples of broadly,
equipment-- and here,
equipment we may even
rise a little bit
as both the physical machinery
and the process environment
that that machinery generates
around the work piece.
So examples might
be an an etch bath.
So that is a liquid
chemical environment
that might be done
under the control
of a piece of equipment.
Other equipment that many of you
may have come in contact with--
things like injection molders,
lathes, drop presses--
and the whole goal of those
are to act on some workpiece.
So we may have silicon with
certain layers already coded
on them.
We may have feedstock,
things like plastic pellets
or [INAUDIBLE], that come in.
We may have sheet metal.
Sheet metal already
may have gone
through an awful
lot of processing,
and we're looking at
a unit step that's
doing some additional
processing on that.
And then the output can
either be a finished part
direct for use or a part that is
in some intermediate stage that
will, again, go and be used
in some larger manufacturing
process.
So it might be a shaft
or a hood or something
like that that's going
to be further assembled,
or an IC chip--
which, from the
semiconductor fab,
that's the finished product.
But from somebody-- can't
remember who said they worked
at Dell--
the IC chip-- that's
not a finished product.
The PC and the assembly--
the packaging and assembly
onto boards and the assembly
of boards into the
[? back plane ?] and so on
are an important
manufacturing process.
So by definition, we're thinking
of a manufacturing process
as a change or the sequence
of changes in some work piece
material.
The easiest way to
conceptualize this
is that it's going to
be a change in geometry.
We're building up some part.
But equally
important is a change
in some material properties,
some constitutive properties
of that structure.
We'll see lots of
examples of that
in semiconductor fabrication.
Here I want to give you a
kind of a generic conceptual
semiconductor process model.
And actually, I want to
mention a little bit--
this ties into the history of
the evolution of this subject.
Back-- oh, God-- it's getting
to be 18 years ago already--
when we were starting to look
at ways to formalize discussion
of semiconductor processing,
we came up with--
myself and some other
co-workers here at MIT
came up with some terminology
for this conceptual
semiconductor process model.
And we talked about
it in terms of states
and transformations of
states, these states
being the geometric state and
the constitutive properties
of the work piece In
semiconductor fabrication,
that's typically the wafer.
And around that,
one is generating
a process or some
environment around the wafer.
That may be gases,
temperature environment,
other kinds of ways of
generating and directing
energy and material at
the surface of the wafer.
The machine itself is a key
controlling parameter for how
one generates that environment,
and the rest of the facility
also impacts that environment--
the feed material coming in,
the very, very high purity
chemicals, for example.
Now, what's important
about the machine
is that the operator
only has limited access.
The operator, which may be human
or may be an automation system,
has only limited access to
that equipment and the facility
through some settings-- some
knob settings, if you will,
that you can perform
on the equipment.
But you also have other
directional sensing capability.
You have some number of readings
that are telling you indirectly
things about the machine--
machine states, sensor
states, thermocouple states,
which are telling you things
about the wafer environment--
and then, indirectly--
if you're lucky, directly
things about the
state of the work
piece itself, telling you things
like the thickness of the film
being grown on the wafer.
And then we had a term,
which is really kind
generic to semiconductor
processing, of a recipe that
basically defined the settings,
and perhaps even could
be generalized to a
control algorithm,
if you will-- which might
be a little bit more
of a generic
terminology-- for dealing
with responses to the readings.
So now you can think about
things like real-time control--
or run by run control, which
we'll talk about later--
that looks at how one determines
what the settings should
be on the equipment.
Now, we came up with a
slightly simplified version
of the semiconductor
process model just focused
on the wafer, the
process, and the settings.
And I want to give you a
real quick example of this.
Actually, I'll probably
skip this and come back
to this next time.
This is looking at examples for
one particular process dealing
with oxidation.
Now, what was
interesting is we came up
with this generic process model.
This was early '90s.
When I came back to
MIT, I started teaching
a subject on
semiconductor process
control dealing with
statistical process modeling,
yield, design of
experiments, and so on.
And then I got involved
in some research
that overlapped with Dave
Hardt and some others.
And he had a course, and--
on manufacturing
process control,
and he had a process model
for control circa 1995.
Maybe you had come up
with it even earlier.
And one of the readings that you
need to grab off of the website
is an overview of
manufacturing processes that
is circa 1995, '96, where
the terminology is almost
exactly the same.
And in fact, the
overlap was astonishing.
The tools and techniques
that I was teaching
in my separate subject and Dave
was teaching in his subject
was about 80% the same, and
then just the process details
kind of changed.
So in fact, we
merged the subject,
and that's how this
subject came about.
And again, the key ideas
here are there are controls.
There is the operator,
and some settings,
and the equipment, material--
that we're all about changing
the geometry and property
through the action of
the process environment,
or these energy states.
Now, in this class,
we're really going
to be focused a lot
on the overall process
outputs [INAUDIBLE]
processes, and in some cases,
the aggregation of those.
And just to get a little
bit of terminology
as a prelude for both
Thursday and next Tuesday,
one can think about a
vector y of characteristics
of the product that
are important--
shape parameters,
particular thicknesses,
perhaps material properties--
like index of refraction
of thin films--
the conductivity of particular
layers, as well as transistor
characteristics, for example.
And that is a function of
the process parameters,
both controls that
one can change
and other parameters that may be
fixed and set for the process.
So a key question is,
what are these alphas?
What are these
process parameters?
And how do we go about
controlling those?
So we'll touch on this picture
a little bit more next time,
but what I want to
skip to here is a--
we'll hear about these different
characterizations or taxonomy
of the process next time.
I want to give you
one last description
building on this very simplified
mathematical terminology
at least for the process,
which is we can go in and--
here we go.
Here we go.
We can split out some of
those process parameters
as those things that
we have control over
as inputs to the process.
And now, if we do just a very,
very simple first-order Taylor
expansion, we get
some nice insight
into where variation comes
in a typical process.
So this is the very
simple variation equation
that, in some sense,
helps structure
what we're going to be doing
through the rest of the term.
One can think about
deviations in the output
deltas in those
characteristics, and we
can expand that in terms of
some of the alpha parameters
and some of the
controllable parameters.
So this dy d alpha-- that's
sensitivity to delta a alphas.
What's delta alphas?
Those are disturbances that you
would prefer were not there.
They're not things that you
intentionally are changing.
Those are inherent
disturbances in the process.
So there's one component
that deals with disturbances.
And then there's also
intentional changes
we might have, when we want to
or intentionally make a change
to the control inputs.
And so what's interesting is
the strategies that we might use
for minimizing this delta y.
And in some sense--
let's see.
Let me get to a
nice summary here.
Here we go.
In some sense, the goal of
the first third of the class--
the techniques we'll be talking
about our statistical process
control, which is
all about detecting
these inherent deviations,
these disturbances,
and seeking to minimize them.
Then we can talk about
process optimization,
things like design
of experiments,
where we're basically trying
to build a model for y--
the output-- as a
function of process
parameters, and seek to
minimize the sensitivity
to those disturbances, to
have as robust a process as
possible.
And then finally,
we can also think
about active modes of process
control, where you actually
manipulate some of the
control parameters,
perhaps in response to
observed deviations,
to ultimately minimize
or counteract,
through feedback control, the
effects of those disturbances.
So that in the
nutshell is the map
for what we're going to be doing
through the rest of the term.
We're going to be dealing, first
off, with statistical process
control and the statistical
background for that.
We're then going to be
modeling the process,
building up design of
experiments, response surface
modeling technologies
for modeling
and optimizing the
process, and then
thirdly, we'll talk about
some basic strategies
for feedback control
to compensate
for some of these processes.
So with that, we'll leave you.
Folks in Singapore, we'll
see you again next week.
Again, do catch the videotape
of Thursday's lecture.
Please go to the website.
This lecture is on there,
but also there are two--
well, there's one reading
that you should grab
right away, which is about a--
was is it-- six or seven
pages process overview
which defines some of this
terminology in written form
that we've talked about here.
And I will also post what
the reading assignment
is that you can get started on.
I don't think it's
posted up there yet,
but go out and try
to get these books,
because there will be-- the
reading assignment is basically
start on the first two chapters,
which are very talkative
overview of
manufacturing processes.
So we'll get you
started on those.
One quick question, Dave--
is there any information on--
is there a pro seminar
when that starts up,
that you want to mention?
DAVID HARDT: Yeah.
2.888 is already-- there's
a Stellar site on it.
I think I've sent most of the
preregistered students notes
on this, but it starts
a week [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: OK.
So we'll have more
information on that.
Many of you, like those enrolled
in the mechanical engineering,
MEng program, will know
about this already,
but this series of seminars from
folks from industry and so on
will quite likely be of interest
to other people in the class.
So we'll start alerting you
about those evening seminars
here as well.
So welcome to the class, and
we'll see you on Thursday.